jean marc sylvestre heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
bonjour alors bruxelles demande des
réformes structurelles on dit que paris
ait visé paris qui n'a pas réagi
est ce que ça peut retarder le versement
de cet argent vous savez oui la question
des aides européennes a déjà pris
beaucoup de retard un accord avait été
conclu en juillet 2020 souvenez-vous il
prévoyait un montant de 700 milliards
d'euros pour l'ensemble des pays de
l'union moitié en subventions moitié en
prêt un prêt garanti par l'europe
et c'était d'ailleurs à ce spectacle là
c'était la première fois que l'europe
s'engage et à mutualiser les dettes on
en parlait déjà depuis très longtemps
cela dit bruxelles a beaucoup tergiversé
parce que bruxelles voulait savoir à
quoi allait servir très précisément cet
argent pas question que ça vienne
financé par exemple des dépenses de
fonctionnement et vous savez tous les
pays de l'europe du nord ont passé à peu
près l'examen ils ont été interrogés
pas de problème la hongrie en revanche
c'est faire remonter les bretelles parce
que la bombe rit on lui a demandé des
réformes d'ordre politique quasiment
institutionnel la hongrie traîne des
pieds l'italie aussi l'espagne la france
également alors en italie l'arrivée de
mario draghi n'est pas étrangère à la
situation du pays alors maintenant que
mario draghi a réussi à rallier toute la
classe politique y compris d'ailleurs
les anti système qui le critiquait
fortement lorsqu'il était président de
la banque centrale
rome aura donc le soutien de bruxelles
et la france dans tout ça c'est votre
question et bien elle avait présenté un
plan de relance qui devait se déplier
sur trois axes un des investissements
pour favoriser la transition digitales
des entreprises de désinvestissement
pour accélérer la mutation écologique la
transformation énergétique et puis 3
pour redynamiser son économie avec une
maîtrise du déficit budgétaire et des
réformes profondes comme celle des
retraites mais tout ça était quand même
encore assez floue alors il va falloir
que tous les pays confirment leur
engagement et la france aussi
mais bruxelles c'est bien que les
promesses finalement ne seront pas
connus surtout lorsqu'il s'agit des
promesses de réformes structurelles
interne
dreux budgétaire je pense par exemple à
la réforme des retraites on vient d'en
parler alors urgent à l'avant-dernière
yen à rappeler chacun à son devoir
elle a fait le job pour calmer un peu
les allemands peut-être aussi pour
tendre le bras des hongrois qui sont pas
sur le mode qui sont pas sur le mode
réforme actuellement
qu'est ce que l'europe peut aller
jusqu'à tout blottissent oui alors elle
peut dire qu'elle peut bloquer a
vraisemblablement elle ne le fera pas
elle trouvera des solutions de compromis
elle ne le peut pas parce que elle elle
peut semer le trouble et amener certains
pays finalement à ne pas voter le plan
de relance ce qui bloquerait la totalité
de la procédure
cela dit je crois pas que ça ira jusque
là parce qu'on a besoin de cet argent la
commission européenne a perdu beaucoup
de son crédit elle doit se défendre par
exemple de son comportement dans la
gestion de la pandémie dans la gestion
de la politique de vaccins avaient été
très attaqué elle va d'ailleurs obligé
aujourd'hui de s'en expliquer auprès du
auprès du parlement cela il dit les pays
de l'union européenne ont beau critiquer
la commission ils ont tous besoin de
l'europe
ils ont aussi besoin de la banque
centrale européenne pourquoi parce que
tous ces pays européens ont besoin
d'emprunter sur les marchés
internationaux
même à titre individuel et s'ils
réussissent à emprunter qui des sommes
qui sont colossales à la france a dû
emprunter l'année dernière plus de 100
milliards elle va d'ailleurs recommencé
cette année à des prix très bas très des
taux zéro quasiment des taux négatifs ça
ça tient du miracle
et bien c'est pas un miracle tout tient
du fait que nous appartenons à l'europe
avec une garantie de la banque centrale
on va donc assister à un jeu de rôle
entre la commission et les gouvernements
dans les habitudes de ce jeu de rôle à
un débat mais ça changera pas grand
chose dans la réalité des faits ça
prendra du retard
sauf qu'une fois de plus il faudra bien
rembourser la dette et c'est un peu ce
que ce que franck celle du linon ben oui
absolument
bruxelles dit qu'il faudra rembourser
christine lagarde d'ailleurs là
également dit haut et fort cette semaine
la dette doit être remboursé elle était
à paris et c'est normal on peut pas
imaginer que l'un des pays européens ne
rembourse pas pourquoi parce que dans ce
cas ce serait la ruine de loin ce serait
la ruine de l'euro no no no no
créanciers ce qui nous prêtent de
l'argent les états du monde entier ne
considérait pas que l'europe serait
crédible donc il se serait il couperait
le
robin est donc impossible tout ça alors
quand on dit cela on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
deux terrains ils s'affrontent
aujourd'hui en europe
vous avez des faucons bull amesys des
durs des sévères j'allais dire des
orthodoxes était classique qui veulent
qu'on rembourse le plus vite possible
des concerts sorties de la pandémie
alors ils sont majoritairement allemands
ils sont aussi très hollandais mais vous
avez aussi à côté des français la
question pour une augmentation assez
rapide une un retour à la normale
budgétaire par augmentation des impôts
vous avez des économistes autour de de
piketty qui ont sorti une tribune
récemment pour réclamer une augmentation
des impôts que les riches payent la
dette qu vite mais c'est pas forcément
la solution bien côté de tout ça ben
vous avez en europe
disons des colons des gens qui sont pas
plus axes la crise mais qui ce soir
d'autres plus pragmatiques qui pensent
eux qu'on a le temps parce que on a
véritablement le temps je le crois du
mois 1les jean-marc selon vous qui peut
l'emporter
et vous je prendrai pas trop de risques
je crois que nous aurons pas de choix
pour une raison très simple c'est que si
on rembourse très vite comme le voeu
qu'un certain nombre d'orthodoxes
classique qui donne pas beaucoup de la
voit d'ailleurs on risquerait de
s'asphyxier on risque de se suicider
économiquement parce que on mettrait en
place des mesures d'austérité qui
assècheraient le système économique et
qui lui empêcherait de financer une
relance notre dette est importante c'est
vrai mais franchement elle ne nous coûte
pas très cher un homme comme un chien
parce que les taux sont très bas et la
croissance économique
il va revenir nous permettra forcément
mécaniquement j'allais dire de raboter
cdec de façon mécanique et cette dette
elle a une maturité de 10 ans et plus
alors on peut mettre dix ans les taux
zéro sont installés pour très longtemps
madame lagarde l'a presque dit
d'ailleurs en début de semaine on peut
attendre cela étant ça ne doit pas nous
empêcher de faire des efforts en matière
de politique budgétaire c'est-à-dire au
niveau des dépenses publiques
on peut continuer d'emprunter c'est vrai
mais à condition que cet argent serve à
des investissements c'est à dire dan
harris mans qui sont porteurs de
richesses qui sont porteurs de
croissance à terme pas question par
exemple d'utiliser cet argent ont bouché
les trous au niveau de la sécurité
sociale au niveau des dépenses de
fonctionnement
n'a évidemment besoin d'investissements
et il faut profiter de ces taux bas pour
les faire merci beaucoup jean marc jean
marc sylvestre
on vous retrouve tous les mercredis
matins dans l'édito de la matinale